un plan d'entreprise pour air france il
a été présenté aujourd'hui par le
président de la compagnie nationale
monsieur giraudet depuis 1974
régulièrement le déficit d'air france se
gonfle ce plan espère redresser la
situation pour 1979
les problèmes sont de deux sortes celui
de la rentabilité en tant qu entreprise
commerciale et celui des contraintes en
tant qu entreprise nationalisée air
france veut bien s'aligner sur la
concurrence mais demande à l'état des
compensations pour ses obligations de
service public
air france c'est une compagnie aérienne
mais c'est aussi une grosse société
commerciale soumise à la fois aux aléas
de la situation économique mondiale et à
la dépendance de son actionnaire
principal l'état français crise du
pétrole stagnation du trafic déficits
énormes
il fallait un plan d'austérité pour
sauver la compagnie les dirigeants
actuels ont choisi la méthode pas de
licenciements massifs parmi les trente
mille employés pourtant jugés trop
nombreux mais réduction des hauts
salaires et surtout surtout amélioration
de la gestion notamment ceux qui
concernent les vieux avions comme les
cars avaient elles consomment trop
beaucoup trop
air france on exploite encore 33 cette
année et voudrait ne plus en avoir des
79 mais alors par quoi les remplacer
et bien tout d'abord par l'airbus
européen de 250 places c'est possible
sur les lignes à gros trafic alors de
huit airbus actuellement air france va
passer à 12 ou peut-être même plus dans
les deux années qui viennent pour les
petites lignes il faut un avions de 100
places environ
va-t-on imposer le dc-9 de douglas ici
en construction aux états unis sous
prétexte d'accord entre les français les
américains sur le mercure 202 d'assaut
les syndicats d'air france n'en veulent
pas car il suffit de deux navigant pour
le piloter il préfère le boeing 737 a
atterri sans ici à miami
il s'agit d'un avion loué par air france
et non acheter faisant la ligne des
antilles de marche est important une
vingtaine d'avions d'ici trois ans mais
la décision est plus politique que
technique et cela nous ramène au
problème de la dépendance pour une bonne
gestion de leur entreprise des
dirigeants de la compagnie nationale vol
que l'état paie
même les services qu'ils demandent
lignes non rentables ligne de prestige
avions imposé et cetera alors air france
pourra rivaliser avec la concurrence et
ne plus dépenser les deniers du
contribuable mais celui du passager